[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Running inference
on compute-heavy
machine learning models
such as face and contour
detection on mobile devices
can be very demanding due to
the device's limited processing
power as well as considerations
such as battery life.
While converting to
a fixed point model
is one way to
achieve acceleration,
we've also had lots of
feedback about GPU support.
So now, we're
excited to announce
a developer preview of a GPU
back end for TensorFlow Lite.
This back end
leverages OpenGL ES
3.1 compute shaders on
Android, and Metal compute
shaders on iOS.
This release is a
pre-compiled binary preview
of the new GPU back end,
allowing you an early chance
to play with it.
We're working on a full open
source release later in 2019,
and would love to hear your
feedback as we shape it.
Let's take a look
at its performance.
We've experimented
with a GPU back end
on a number of models, including
four public ones and two
internal models that we
use in Google products.
The results showed that the GPU
back end worked two to seven
times faster than a floating
point CPU implementation.
You can see the GPU inference
time in orange and the CPU
inference time in gray.
We tested this on an iPhone
7, a Pixel 2, and a Pixel 3,
amongst others, and this was
the average inference time
across 100 tests on each
of these devices for each
of these models.
The speed up was most
significant on more complex
models, the kind
that lead themselves
better to GPU utilization.
On smaller and
simpler models, you
may not see such a
benefit because of,
for example, the time
cost of transferring data
into GPU memory.
So I'm sure your next question
is, how do I get started?
Well, the easiest way
is to try our demo
apps that use the GPU delegate.
We have written a tutorial
to walk you through this,
and I'll put a link to it in
the description for this video.
There's also a couple
of really nice screen
casts showing you how to
get up and running quickly.
There's one for Android
and one for iOS,
and I've linked to them too.
For Android, we've
prepared a complete Android
archive that includes TensorFlow
Lite with the GPU back end.
When you use this, you can then
initialize the TensorFlow Lite
interpreter using the GPU
back end with this code.
On iOS and C++, you can use
modify graph with delegate
after creating your
model with this code.
All of this is done for
you in the sample app,
so download it
and give it a try.
Now, not all operations are
supported by the GPU back end
at this moment.
Your model will run
fastest when it uses
only the GPU supported ops.
Others will automatically
fall back to the CPU.
To learn more about GPU,
including a deep dive
into how it works, check
out the documentation
on TensorFlow.org,
which also has
a bunch of details
on optimizations,
performance best practices,
and a whole lot more.
This is just the beginning
of our GPU support efforts.
We're continuing to add more
optimizations, performance
improvements, and API
updates all the time,
but would love to hear your
feedback on our GitHub page.
We'd also love to hear
your feedback on YouTube,
so don't forget to hit
that Subscribe button.
And if you've any
questions or comments,
just please leave in
the comments below.
Thank you.
Are you excited to see what's
new with TensorFlow in 2019?
We've got lots of great
new content coming,
and it's all going to be covered
right here on the YouTube
channel.
So whatever you do, don't forget
to hit that Subscribe button,
and we'll see you there.